un combattant mais ça ne te virera pas
sans clé en or massif d'
accord ben je suis bricoleur avec un matos photo
rien je me souviens de l'aspirateur Oh produit
pila tu resteras sur cette fréquence
du tout et vol Groenland ou pas on
honnêtement les autres trucs vont bien  d'accord
nous sommes juste à ce moment-là pour ce que vous
voulez commander pour copier et nous restons sur cette
fréquence
j'ai un moment nous nous dirigeons vers le
kazakh probablement la seule chance d'
avoir l'avion ici enfin allez
plus léger tout le monde appelle ça  à propos de plusieurs
positions, nous avons eu le test il y a des semaines à
propos de l'image satellite et plein plein
plein du grand écran est magnifique vous
avez le GPS sur cette voiture sur celle-ci l'
autre point GPS maintenant nous ne le faisons pas mais nous
avons dessiné en dessinant sur le  rencontré avec
foi nous avons volé